انا وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيان ان طيران ستتاخذ الاجراءات
المناسبه للرد على قرار مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه الذي صدر الاسبوع الماضي
ضدها واضاف عبد الله هيان في مؤتمر الصحفي
مع نظيره العماني في طهران ان قرار
الوكاله ياتي ضمن سياسه الضغوط القصوى
وتاثير على الداخل الايراني استغلال
الوكاله السياسيه حسب تعميره
الاسبوع الماضي اجراءات غريبه ضد ايران
وهذا الاجراءات بينما سافر وفي منظمه
الطاقه الذريه والخارجيه الايرانيه
الاسبوع الماضي
كان بناءا واتفقوا على تعزيز التعاون بين
ايران والوكاله لكن فجاه تم اصدار في
اجتماع مجلس محافظ الوكاله وهذا
الاجراءاتي في اطار السياسه الضغوط القصوى
والتاثير على الداخل الايراني
تسعى الى استغلال الوكاله السياسيه وسنرد
عليها بكل تاكيد برد متناسب وفي الوقت
نفسه نحترم القوانين وتعهداتنا الدولي
كما قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه ان
الوجود العسكريه الاجنبيه في المنطقه يهدد
ان مياه الخليج وبحر عمان والمنطقه بشكل
عام واعتبر الوزير الايراني ان الوجود
العسكريه الاجنبي يشكل تهديدا لامن الطاقه
مشيرا الى ان دول المنطقه قادره على ضمان
انها فقد تعبيره
ونؤمن بان القوات العسكريه الاجنبيه تعتبر
تهديدا لمنطقه الخليج الفارسي وبحر عمان
وتهديدا لامن الطاقه في هذه المنطقه هناك
عدد كبير من المسرات المائيه الاجنبيه
التي تتحرك في الخليج الفارسي وبحر عمان
وهذا الامر ادى الى تفاقم الوضع الامني في
منطقتنا دولنا قادره على ضمان امل المنطقه